hi everyone I'm yupong and this is Nan
my colleague here uh we're very happy to
be here today uh to talk about like
Uber's metric system and share our
journey that always give it up from
United search to P node
um so just quickly about ourselves you
know my
photos like resolution is not that good
but I'm a principal engineer at Uber and
I lead a real-time data platform our
platform built on top of Open Source
softwares like Apache Kafka fulling and
keynote and this talk is mainly about
like Pinot myself also a Pinot uh
commuter and my colleague now he's a
staff engineer he's from mobility and
platform team and that his team in
charge of the Uber's business Matrix
system and yeah here we go So today
we're going to first introduce a new
metric our business mattress system at
Uber we'll give an overview on why we
build data and what it does and then
we'll talk about like our initial
architecture of it
search and also the challenges like we
encounter over the years
then we talk about like how we resolve
these issues and challenges by moving to
Apache pinot and that's what I will give
you a high level overview about like you
know Uber
um why we're chosen on our journey with
it and also along with some
contributions we made to this open
source software by Bridging the gaps
between like search and keynote and also
solve some of the stability issues that
we have with uh our metric system and
then lastly we'll conclude with some
future work that we planned before their
contribution to this software
with this I will pass to another talk
about our metric system
even can I have the
right thank you
so before we talk about your metric
system we can we need to know how
decisions are made in Uber which is
highly data driven and just like most of
the tech company these days if we take
an image on the left side this is when
you're trying to order a chip from Uber
headquarter to San Francisco the
original price is around 44 dollars and
that price has actually calculated
behind by Dynamic pricing algorithm the
example version of that is for example
it will check the marketplace demand and
Supply condition for the last 10 minutes
for this specific area and when the
market is oversupplied the price will be
lower and the vice versa
and the 35 is the updated price after
the promotion and now the promotion
value the budget is also made by data
analysis for each area at a certain
period of time and after that budget
being divided by everybody it's the
promo you see on the app
and on the right side we can see the
trip search flow for San Francisco area
now this is the visualized version of
the data and the table version combined
with many metrics such as the trip
number gross booking value Supply hour
that is being widely used by DS dapm and
Ops for all sorts of decision making
so we need data and real-time data and
offline data
volumetric
why cannot every team use their own
pipeline to calculate their own fact and
use that for their purposes
well that actually is the fact for long
while and the trouble is that every team
is creating their own version of the
business metric for example completed
trip and a yearly use that in all kind
of occasions like a business report or
fact sharing but the problem is that
every team is using slightly different
logic when they're creating those
metrics so when the other result is
being shared across it's like apple to
Orange comparison not exactly accurate
and for Uber's use cases especially the
data Precision matters even just one
percent or two percent of the
discrepancy can turning for example
gross booking a profitable business into
your last one so we need to avoid this
and the solution is obviously
standardization and unification
with all of the computation the metric
definition to be unified everybody is
using the same table created by same
pipeline naturally that problem will be
solved
and the ways the use case is being
centralized over to a single platform we
can do much more things for example
check the data quality guarantee the SRA
improve the query performance and the
computation performance so everything
will have higher standard
and there are many other companies in
the industry obviously is doing such
work for the years such as the Airbnb
and Linkedin and there's so many more
and in Uber we call this umetric
it is a unified metric platform that
manage the full life cycle of a metric
from definition Discovery all the way to
computation verification and storage and
serving
and behind this metric system naturally
we need a very powerful data platform to
do all the computation and Storage
and for the years we built that around
elasticsearch it's actually since 2014.
now here's a very simple workflow on the
right side we have the data coming from
Kafka a distributed message queue from
user devices and the real-time systems
and then the data is being computed by
the Flink pipelines which is a real-time
data computation framework
and after all of the filtering
aggregation Logics applied the data is
being stored in elasticsearch cluster
and then periodically we are dumping the
data from elasticsearch to hive by spark
for long-term analysis
in meanwhile for the user users on the
right side such as real-time system and
bigger screen dashboard machine learning
models they're all going to be consuming
these data through our query later
now while Asic search
I think we made the decision again in
very early stage around 2014 and there
were few requirements we had
specifically at the time one is it must
be operable by a small team Uber didn't
have a dedicated team managing olap
system yet such as Droid or clickhouse
and the managing of these systems
actually require a lot of expertise and
the human we have only a few engineers
at the time so it's not a feasible
option for us
and then we need to support strong
absurd and that is statically required
by Uber's table for example chip table
we have the real-time trip table that
has the state being updated all the time
continuously all the way things is being
created and then assigned to the driver
and then the pickup started completed
until the trip finish and we will be
have the need to keep updating the same
role continuously with attached logic
and absurd is a must for that
we need to support the aggregating
aggregation naturally because it's
aggregation use case and the system must
be linearly scalable to support
uberscale data set and at last it must
be a material system that's being widely
used by different companies and teams
over years so that we wouldn't step into
a lot of issues initial usage
and we started with serving the
real-time use cases only like Dynamic
pricing and Marketplace health and for
all of these years has been keep growing
and supporting more users until today
we're storing 1.5 petabytes of data
combined with 4.5 trillion documents the
writing QPS is around 1.3 million per
second and the reading scanning per
second is around 700 million per second
so there is quite a wild number for
elasticsearchs especially and naturally
the native framework we designed earlier
wouldn't be suitable for computation in
the scale
so we did all sorts of optimization on
top of it and the box is seeing deep
green are the ones that we did for
optimization
they're actually much more than we
showed here but we sure picked a few
that might be interesting to the crowd
one the optimization we did from cluster
and the query side
now Shadow routing is something that is
natively supporting elasticsearch and
then we later applied elasticsearch is
partitioned by a concept called sharding
by default
but this is not effective for the
queries with a certain Dimension hit for
example City you're still doing a whole
index scan which is a waste so if you
can logically partition your table based
on city it can effectively avoid this or
index scan which is what we used but
naturally discovering the key for the
table require a
analysis over the query history so we
build a system to do that automatically
and the next thing is Shadow I mean
circuit breaker so this is a function
allow you to kill the query where it's
over using its results on the fly so
that it wouldn't bring down the old
cluster
and I think this feature was evaluated
by us on 2016 or 15.
and at the time in-flight circuit
breaker is only supporting cutting the
traffic when the payload size is huge
from the request or response so we
haven't we added a function to check the
result of the memory usage to make sure
that it wouldn't cause other memory
issue
next thing is the optimization on
streaming side naturally this is the
part we heavily invested but the most
interesting case I want to share is a
dynamic array limiting now we have the
case that a fling job can actually stop
for a short while like 10 minutes or 15
minutes and then Encore noticed the
issue and who tried to restart the job
or fix it and once the job started again
it'll be dumping the data for the past
15 minutes all the way to the cluster
that could be 10 times of the regular
traffic and it's going to be crushing
the cluster in only a few seconds
there are many options we had to solve
the problem and one of the most
interesting one actually is a rate limit
except one uh fling doesn't have a rate
limiting supported in elasticsearch sync
so we added one and the two we do wish
the cluster to process as much data as
possible when surrounding healthy hence
the dynamic we're going to be sensing
the cluster Health in near real time and
whenever the Clusters underperform we're
going to slow down the writing otherwise
we're going to lift the rate limit to a
very high value so they can process as
fast as possible to recover this 15
minute lagging
next thing row up and the catch now roll
up has a native function supported in
most of the olap system like Droid or
click house but not a not elasticsearch
not since 8 point X version and it's
still not real time and we're still
using 5x so at the time we created
framework to define the row up syntax
and table our own with these tables
being pre-computed we don't need to scan
the raw table which is relatively large
and a catch now for two real-time use
case catches relatively useless because
it's hitting too many documents and
documents that keep being updated which
causing the catch to be invalidated
easily but we do have a lot of use cases
who doesn't care too much about the
freshness for example the Big Spring
dashboard they just care about the data
from one hour ago so for them we're
going to be creating a catch layer for
them with a time to live served for one
hour and naturally they can reuse the
catch they already hit
both of these approach can drastically
bring down the load to hitting the route
table
and the next one the neckline next one
is backfill so we experience a lot of
the data loss issue the minor ones
actually we need to deal with that in a
daily basis we had the
Lambda and the card architecture being
used over years to do end-to-end
computation but naturally whenever we do
the recompute it takes at least one day
of the data to do so and this is a very
expensive process so meanwhile we have
observation that we actually have a lot
of copy of the same table over in
different clusters and the data center
it's quite rare for them to broke at the
same time simultaneously so what do we
do is to use elasticsearch index API to
copy the healthy polishing of the data
from the healthy cluster to the other
broken one and it can be with any
granularity for example even five
minutes or a few minutes
and unfortunately native elasticsearch
uh re-index API it's only running in
single-sided fashion and it doesn't have
a lot of functions such as automatically
retry or Etc so we wrote a service on
our own which allow us to run the
elastic search index in parallel with
auto retry and with more humanly uh
interactive way to make it easier to
operate with and eventually this
performance of this queue is 30 times
better than the native ringbacks API
but with all of the optimization we've
done over the years there's still many
challenges that we're facing and the
leading one is reliability the cluster
overloads a lot which causing sa breach
and the minor data loss
and
we have very limited mitigation method
as well we can either choose to fail
over it to the other data center or we
can throw in another 20 30 nodes into
the existing cluster and none of these
are ideal and the worst of law is that
we can never able to root cause the
issue which means it can't happen again
anytime
and regarding scalability
umetric is a rapidly growing service
with many users need to be onboarded and
our concern on the reliability because
becomes a bottleneck for us to
onboarding them and uh even in theory we
can always linearly scale elasticsearch
cluster
the ROI for that is actually relatively
low because we have to throw another 50
or 60 percent of the cluster and nodes
into the cluster just to avoid the
potential reliability issue we have and
at your certain point we need to look at
the cost and we're going to find Roi is
relatively low
and then it is the engineering cost all
of the optimization system I mentioned
before all of these these Tech Engineers
time to develop and the plus with the
instance that we have all the time
Beyond call load is quite heavy
so obviously we need a way out there
were a few options we had at the time we
can choose to upgrade elasticsearch to
later version 8.x there's some functions
we think might be helpful to the
situation we can choose to keep
developing those optimization tools we
have we're not out of ideas there are
many
or maybe it's time for us to embrace a
true olap system which has Beauty in row
up which has columnar storage which has
Federated storage
and at the time Uber is already using
peanut as the olap system widely used in
the company so that's where we go
and there is a past migration to there
and it's definitely not ping free as
easy as you'd create a new tables
entering the traffic there everything's
good actually not so simple
so first of all we need to deal with the
giant feature gaps between elasticsearch
and peanut
first one is absurd absurd was not uh
added for any of the olap system at the
time not Droid not clickhouse but after
discussion with the peanut team they
finally has this function added and as
of today the full document is fully
supported by tens of our tables and for
the partial absurd while the logic
expression is a little limited but we
made it work for the tables we require
that as well
and then this backfill now we use more
for cover copper architecture to do
backfill these days which is through
Flink and the
peanut doesn't really have a filling
connector allow us to directly writing
there so piano team edit as well
and then their stock connector which is
required to dump data from Pinot to Hive
this is also added and already
integrated with our system
and the last nested column support
peanut is by native only support flat
volume we also took a look with peanut
team on this case and turn out there are
too many Pinot components we need to
change to make a you know nested calling
support so we made some work around our
new metric site instead now the queries
are actually not consumed by users in
real time directly they're reading
metric so the users doesn't need to know
what the query pattern looks like by
changing the metric definition the user
wouldn't be aware of the schema change
at all the tricky part is the hive
because users do need to read that
directly so what do we do is that we're
storing the nested to Flat relationship
of each table somewhere in the config
system and when we're dumping data from
Pinot to Hive we can massage the data
frame to restoring that into the nested
schema as if it was reading from classic
search and with these changes applied
the users wouldn't be aware of the
skimmer change at all
and then that is the safe migration
the contacts on that is that when
migrating the tables created for the
past 80 years hundreds of tables and
even more thousands of metrics to be
migrated and we cannot eat that as a
one-hole so we develop a series of
systems to allow us to migrate that
safely one of which is to compare the
query performance and the result and the
data quality and the reliability across
elasticsearch and peanut before we
migrate and by which we measure the
query duration for performance we
measure the value discrepancy by data
quality and we value how much loaded
peanut cluster increases for each query
for the reliability and we do this for
every query we train over and then we
designed a very powerful draining system
allowing us not only to dream traffic by
table and Metric but also by user and
retention as well for example today we
can train a user when it's hitting
metric a on table B if the query is
within the latest months we can hit that
with peanut otherwise it's still reading
elasticsearch this powerful draining
system allows us to solve this problem
in divide and conquer fashion
and there with limits time with limited
time I cannot dive into Performance
Tuning now but we did all sorts of
proponents tuning Our hardware and
algorithm and aggregation function layer
as well
and now the aftermath
so we see drastic improvement on the
reliability much less incidence alerts
after migration and the plus this
integration granted us the power to
dream the trafficking table level versus
earlier we can only drink by the cluster
we also see the bottleneck on the
scalability has been resolved and
meanwhile we can actually scale the
table on demand on table layer
engineering cost wise we no longer need
to develop those optimization systems
anymore and inside it can allow us to
deprecate the existing six systems we
already developed and at the meanwhile
the uncle load is decreased because of
the test alerts
and then you can tell us more about
peanut and Uber and how do they make
this happen
thanks
all right thank you Nan for sharing our
journey on the migration on metric
system so I will talk about like how we
use you know Uber in general and then
particularly around you know how we
reach these gaps as none talk about
um so before it pop up this Matrix I
want to talk give a highlight overview
about the real-time analytics which is
very exciting domain uh and area at Uber
um that we basically use like Apache P
node as a core system uh like to empower
management Mission critical use cases so
for RTI Uber with many libraries for
three purposes uh one at real time and
actionable insights you know as you know
Uber's business is a highly based on
like real-time data and we want to
provide this real-time information and
capture this in our like applications
which we call this like user facing
analytics so on the left hand side you
see a screenshot which is uh called
restaurant manager that we built this
for the restaurant owners who can use
this to manage their restaurants across
the globe and from there they can see
why real-time information for example
the missing orders or the any like
ongoing issues that demand like
immediate attention and take actions
uh another category because it's like
time sensitive decisions and work
examples our fulfillment system uh so
it's like you know in the middle of this
uh the diagram where we have like
constant upcoming user requests could be
you know like riders or eaters that are
making a requests and we also have like
um like um the supply which our drivers
or couriers who can take these orders
right so we need like a dynamic balance
between the demand and supply and a core
like decision Beyond this is the
real-time information when you know
where these request coming from and
based on the Geo locations and we do
look at like how much Supply we have in
this area so as example sure by now
talking about the dynamic pricing is one
good example of like how can make this
like time-sized decisions based on a
real-time signal
unless they also realize that real-time
information is very powerful for
increasing the user engagement so on the
right hand side you see this is like its
application
um like it's like school card we build
for Uber free carriers where they can
use this to track their
um the free carrier real-time
performance and give them feedback to
show how they are doing are they
delivering like stuff like on time or
any real-time feedback so from this
fancy like
almost all the like critical metrics
improved for the like for this like a
business unit like a career
um so
and then we look at this business metric
as a whole right so we feel like we can
solve this large category of problems
um by our like pinot and Uber but over
like root analytics platform
um so in short the mission of this
platform is to provide fast access to
fresh data at scale
and at the core we use open source
software it's called Apache Pino which
is a fast distributed system o-lab
system so originally this software was
built by LinkedIn and interesting for
their metric system
so uh it's initial like uh goal for this
system to be highly available
to be able to horizontally scale when
the demand increase and also they want
to cover the low latency higher
throughput like data pattern and lastly
as part of the system design they rely
on the immutable data which back then
was quite popular for like common uh Big
Data softwares for example spark and
when I think about immutable is like can
be can be very fast right uh so this was
a key difference from elasticsearch so
l1k were very very high level
architecture overview of like the
architecture of P node you can think of
like a table of Pinos is consists of
multiple segments so what we came from
this that means like data is uh it can
be split and it can store in a
distributed way so that means we can
have much higher throughput and Battery
management through a digital system
and we distribute this data across
different servers so the panning phase
is that we can increase the number of
replica as we add more servers in order
to improve the availability and also the
stability so the holidays we can be more
like horizontally scalable
and we use a central control plane
without help zookeeper and on top that
is a helix which is also Apache software
contributed by Linkin as a classroom
management so this kind of like like
share nothing architecture that also
help us to horizontally scale the system
as we need
and when there's like user query
accounts mean this you will talk to we
call this like penal broker and the
whole architecture is built on top of
like LSM architecture which is like a
log structure merger tree which is known
to be like highly scalable and for high
throughput like uh systems and use cases
and then we add real-time servers and
offline servers for data ingestion to
generally like real time like data
putting on the servers and then this
service can be acquired by the Pinot
broker
um and over this core over the years we
build a platform we call like ever
uh and try to improve the usability and
make the ease of management of clusters
and also improve the query experience so
this is like it's a we call the like
tier zero platform uh you know I Uber
will label different Services by its uh
how critical they are and tier zero
means the most critical system with like
four nights like uptime
uh and this also provides self-service
onboarding which we invest a lot on
making the use onboarding experience
nice so that I like when used Ubuntu
onboard use case at the Pinot table or
setup pipeline they do not need to
engage with our Pino team but instead
they can go to a UI which is called you
work and the two click a few buttons and
then data can be on boarded and the
adjustment will start
and we also have an integration between
P node and Presto we call this neutrino
to provide like Presto SQL flavor to
interact with this Aquarius system
um and also contribute this to the
Presto Community as well
so as today uh our platform can provide
second level like data freshness
and also most of queries can finish
within 100 milliseconds so this kind of
will be like low latency high throughput
like Vision that we realized
um so I bought on their link where we
publish engineering blog to talk about
how we can operate this system at Uber
scale and there are many interesting
lessons that we learned along the years
and back tool is a business Matrix
system as none talked about there are
actually several interesting technical
challenges and gaps that we want to
Bridge and the one outstanding one is
absurd so as I mentioned that like you
know the data model is based on
immutable data which makes it very
difficult to make changes and in fact
like back then there was no like real
life system on Market that support
absurd so this is like about the cool
feature like uber contribute to the open
source community and why do we need this
right so let's give you a quick example
you can see on the right hand side you
want to build like a dashboard to show
like how many ongoing orders
by the status like how many orders
delivered how many orders are ongoing
and how many are newly created to be
assigned
um so with absurd we can easily write a
SQL query on the left that I can Group
by the current status but the status
will change constantly over the time
right so without absurd you'll be very
difficult almost impossible to write a
single serial query uh to to achieve
this
due to the time limit I do not have time
to go through the technical details of
how we can make this happen but
otherwise high level our ideas to build
a lineage that we can track how the data
was modified
and the data is still immutable but we
know for a given particular data for
example one is order like which segments
this other information like it's stored
and then we have a Central View to
derive the current view from this linear
of like information
so if you're interested about the
details you can go check out the YouTube
link where we presented about how we
make absurd work at the piano Meetup
so another interesting feature that we
contribute is the complex support
so originally pin only supports our
primitive data it's like long integer
string and for good reasons right
because Pinot is designed for like high
throughput low latency like use cases so
it wants to be very fast right so how to
make things fast just keep it simple
right so you have like primitive like
web values you just use like simple
arrays so with such a simplified data
model we can make quite execution very
efficient
but for use cases like business metrics
we have a complex type defined by the
users like for example on the live you
can see uh they will have nice structure
of like Maps so there could be like
um like a group and then this group
could have like less different fields
and we also have a race like so in
addition to this each of this group
object can be like a complex structure
so we thought about like how we can like
improve this and in fact I Pinot there
are actually two different routes to
support that one way is to convert this
into a Json object and then Pinot has a
Json indexing support
and in other words like we have an
inbuilt like rule base like translation
so that given a complex structure uh we
apply this Rule and then we can write
this uh object on the fly so a good
thing about the second approach is that
we can support all kinds of like query
constructs like for example you can
Group by some nasty field which is not
possible in a decent way but it's doable
like using the second approach
so for more details you can read about
the documents we put on the piano like
uh like web page to show like some
interesting like techniques behind this
and we also want to talk about like a
few connectors we we contributed so one
is the spark connector so this actually
I Uber widely used like by copying from
penal data into hype dispersal
and we actually made good contributions
by improving the performance and
throughput and reload entire connector
using grpc for much much better like a
performance
another interesting contribution is the
flame connector so this kind of like
shows the diagram on the right uh you
know so while the good motivation for us
is to do like back view so I talk about
like the upstairs table and actually
pretty challenging to backfill for like
large upstairs tables in order to
achieve this we built this like fitting
connector
uh another modification for us which is
we have like a pretty big like Vision
that we want to unify like streaming on
a batch like pipelines uh you know Pinot
has a concept of like hybrid table which
is pretty common right so so you have a
table and you have a real-time part
where data isn't just in real time for
example for the past few seconds past
few minutes or past few hours right but
you also want to keep like the
historical part of this table for
example past three days past one month
so that can give you a federal view to
see from let's say three years ago to
the past few seconds you want to see
everything
architecture where people use a flint
job to build a real-time part uh
transformation processing and then we
use a spark job to do the batch
computation for better performance for
better efficiency
um so but one challenge to the engineers
that they have to write the same
pipeline twice in different languages in
different Lego Frameworks at least one
influing or one in spark so what I start
thinking about like can we unify this
can people just write one pipeline like
for example just run free and Flink and
then this spring job can run in
streaming fashion over Kafka or work in
the batch version over the hype tables
so well inspired by companies like
Alibaba where they contribute a lot to
the fling framework to realize this
vision and it's kind of like one of the
attempts from oversized
by building this connect service P node
that we can simplify this like ingestion
story
so um our start now stop here we're
actually actually working on different
features and improvements uh to the
Pinot community and this spinner project
so among those I I only highlight a few
that are relevant to
um this like metric system like a few
features for example
um that
who are building on top of the uh this
uh like structure index which is pretty
cool like index format from
um like Pinot that gives like a balance
between how much extra storage you want
to put uh to save the time when you run
complex aggregation query so you can
think of like here this kind of the low
up pipelines but these are like embedded
pipelines that generated or maintained
by the peanut system itself so that user
do not need to write extra pipelines uh
outside this system
um so the core of this is a it's called
like the star tree index that come with
a Pinot or generally contribute by
LinkedIn and here our vision is like we
want to replace many existing such lower
pipelines just to use this start to
inject index
and also uh working on like better class
isolation and better tiering for the ESL
deployment so you know rapidity is
always on top of our mind and product
efficiency is another right so such a
better
um class iOS installation is upgrade for
like improving the safe deployments and
also ease of management
and lastly you know we contribute The
observed feature to P node and we are
still have good ideas on how we can make
this more efficient more powerful one
example is about the compaction so as
mentioned before about absurd by uh so
the data we can be keep appendage and
because data is mutable right but over
the time we see the data become bloated
because like the same record can be
modified again and again but for the
historical part of the same record that
that will not need to change and
therefore particularly we can run some
background thread that can do the data
compaction and then make the segment
much smaller and therefore can save the
space
another cool idea we are thinking about
is called like a TTL besides based on
the observation that uh like people
won't absurd
um but I typically it upstairs may only
apply to like a session like for example
like uber session probably May last a
few hours or at most a day right and
outside this session we know this record
will never change like for example very
unlikely that people will go back to
three months ago and modify some data
there so if we can have such like prior
knowledge then we can say okay let's
only keep the absolute TTL for you know
a couple of days and as a result we can
release much of the memory because we
have to remember where this records uh
resides across different segments right
so here are some examples of my vision
that are worth thinking about and there
are also other cool features that Uber
is actively working on to contribute to
this open source software
so this concludes our session uh and
thanks to everyone thanks everyone for
attending this talk
[Music]